[Music]
hi guys this is sam claflin and i play
henry copper in the new movie book of
love today i'm going to play a game
where i basically have to try my hardest
to pronounce the most difficult spanish
words i have no idea what these words
are i have no idea what any of them mean
but i'm going to be guessing also what i
think they mean a little drum roll
please for
meteorologi
meteorology
methodological
meteorological material meteorological
and i believe that that is
meteor meteorology i've heard of the
word meteorology but i don't really know
what it is actually so even the english
interpretation of this word no idea
[Music]
holy crikey
idiosyncrasia
idiosyncrasia
idiosyncrasia
which i believe means idiosyncrasy i
don't already again i don't know the
meaning of that word is either
[Music]
and it means
pies in an arch
arch pies on largo isn't that a country
i don't know as a city i don't know
archipelagio
[Music]
uh
zara
like a zebra crossing
uh that's me
in in in spanish
[Music]
serotonin
corkscrew
[Music]
actually stairs i can hear that now
i don't know my pronunciation is
probably way off but
you know i do i do like a good old sacha
horseshoes so yeah go out and buy one
now and then go and see my movie book of
love because
we need all the sakura horchos that we
can get
for you i'm the translator of your book
why are all these people here i made
some changes
what have you done to my book
oh my lord i know
[Music]
you